my husband's looking forward to it we  have a three-year-old and he's still  looking for like he's like it's gonna be  so exciting he is a wonderful age they  are a major though but yeah he's our boy  yeah we call it Tuesday fine threes are  the devil his act from inside their body  and I need an X or so you you're  drinking communion every night I drink a  lot of community it wasn't my fault  Jesus changed that water yes I don't  need water are you bothering them to  have green kids yet though because  they're another on the house oh yes in  fact I do it nationally like every talk  show I go on okay where's that what  camera should I look at this one right  here okay boys I'm just letting you know  the first one that gives me a grandchild  gets the house I will not stop talking  until you subscribe to my youtube  channel that's right and I could talk a  lot seriously not gonna stop yep still  here not going anywhere I see you don't  walk away from this